ron desantis gave his state of the state
and i wanted to
show you a couple clips from it and i
will leave it up to you to decide for
yourself whether you think the vision
that this guy florida man ron desantis
is putting forth is a vision of a
country and a state that you would want
to live in that protects your rights
cares about you as the individual
doesn't believe that it is designed to
govern over you forever or if you think
joe biden's better and will juxtapose
some desantis and biden clips florida
has become the escape hatch for those
chafing under authoritarian arbitrary
and seemingly never-ending mandates and
restrictions and the kids used to come
up and reach into the pool and rub my
leg down so it was straight and then
watch the hair
come back up again
they'd look at it so i learned about
roaches i learned about kids jumping on
my lap
and i've loved kids jumping on my lap we
reject the biomedical security state
that curtails liberty
ruins livelihoods and divides our
society and we will protect the rights
of individuals to live their lives and
cornpop was a bad dude provided our
businesses with the ability to prosper
fought back against unconstitutional
federal mandates
look fat look here's the deal
here's the deal even today across the
nation
we see students denied an education
due to reckless politically motivated
school closures
workers denied employment due to
heavy-handed mandates you're a lion
dog-faced pony soldier in florida we
have protected the right of our citizens
to earn a living all these truths to be
self-evident
all men and women created by the go you
know the you know the thing
they are grounded more in blind
adherence to fountain declarations than
they are in the constitutional
traditions that are the foundation of
free nations
florida is a free state let's go brandon
i agree
all right i don't want to be
heavy-handed though so i'm not even
going to say any more about this you
guys just
take all of that and think about how you
want to go forward with your life what
type of person would you want
governing someone like you desantis or
corkbot
you decide